hey this is preshtal Walker let ABC be
the triangle with a b equal to 1 AC
equal to 3 and angle BAC equal to pi
over 2. if a circle of radius R greater
than zero touches the sides a b a c and
also touches internally the circumcircle
of the triangle ABC then the value of R
is blank
this problem was question 8 on the je
Advanced 2022 paper one I think Rahul
and buttu for suggesting the problem and
I also give credit to unacademy Adams
video solution
which helped me understand how to solve
the problem
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
before I explain the solution I want to
go over an important concept if two
circles are tangent their centers and
the tangent Point are collinear
so here we have circles A and B that are
tangent at a point T this principle says
that ATB is a straight line segment
to understand why construct the tangent
line through Point t
then because T is a tangent point a t
will be perpendicular to the tangent
line and BT will be perpendicular to the
tangent line therefore ATB will be a
straight line segment this is true for
both externally and internally tangent
circles
so now let's solve the problem
we have the triangle ABC
a b is equal to one and AC is equal to
3.
angle BAC is equal to pi over 2 which is
equal to 90 degrees so angle a is a
right angle
that means BC is the hypotenuse so it
will be equal to the square root of the
square of 1 plus the square of 3. this
is equal to the square root of 10.
we now want to construct the
circumcircle of ABC
now because angle a is a right angle
The Arc that it subtends in the
circumcircle will be 180 degrees this
means that BC will be the diameter of
the circumcircle so the hypotenuse is
the diameter of the circumcircle so BC
is the diameter which means half of BC
will be the radius so let's construct
the midpoint of BCM and then c m and MB
will both be radii of the circumcircle
and each of them will be equal to 0.5
multiplied by the square root of 10.
now
because m is the midpoint it will be
exactly half the horizontal distance of
a b and half the vertical distance of AC
so from point A it'll be 0.5 units to
the right and 1.5 units up
now let's construct this circle which is
tangent to the sides a b and AC and is
internally tangent to the circumcircle
label the center of this circle as d
now this circle and the circumcircle of
the triangle are tangent at a point t
so by the principle MDT will be a
straight line segment
let's suppose the radius of this smaller
Circle DT is equal to R
then Mt is a radius of the circumcircle
so we know its radius is equal to 0.5
multiplied by the square root of 10. so
MD will be the difference of the radii
so MD will be equal to 0.5 multiplied by
the square root of 10 minus r
now let's consider the horizontal and
vertical distance to D from the point a
now we'll construct the following radii
so the Circle D is tangent to a b and
it's tangent to AC so each of these will
be radii
so now we've constructed a square
between the points A and D
so each side length of the square will
be a radius of the circle D so each of
these distances will be equal to R
now let's consider the horizontal and
vertical distances between m and d
we can find this as the difference
between R and 0.5 and the difference
between R and 1.5
so we figured out the horizontal and
vertical distances between m and d
we now just focus on this right triangle
let's say this point is e and that's the
right angle
so we have a right triangle and we know
the lengths of the legs and we know the
length of the hypotenuse
so we have me squared plus E D Squared
is equal to MD squared
we substitute in for these lengths and
we get the following equation so we have
a single equation in R and we just need
to solve for r
so let's focus on this equation
to solve it we will expand the binomials
now we will group like terms so we have
r squared plus r squared on one side and
then we have r squared on the other side
so that'll cancel out to be r squared on
the left hand side
then we'll group The R terms
finally we'll look at the constant terms
we have 2.25 plus 0.25 and that's equal
to 2.5 so that'll exactly cancel with
the 2.5 on the right hand side
so this equation becomes r squared minus
4r plus r multiplied by the square root
of 10 is equal to 0.
we Factor an R from this equation
then the radius has to be greater than
zero by the given information in the
problem
so we exclude the solution R is equal to
zero and we just have the solution R is
equal to 4 minus the square root of 10
which is approximately equal to 0.84 and
that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign